[Music]
on this saturday night
a hockey legend's tribute to his dad
walter gretzky is remembered as the
captain of a family
he has the heart of gold and
just wonderful a canadian treasure laid
to rest
vaccination acceleration the proposal to
give shots
24 7 in canada's largest city
100 days the farmer's protest in india
and the political implications for
canada plus the sweet success story
peace is the noblest valley on air that
everyone should fight for
from syrian refugee to canadian
[Music]
entrepreneur
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us a small funeral was held in brantford
ontario to honor one of canada's
proudest hockey dads
walter gretzky the father of canadian
hockey legend wayne gretzky
was laid to rest in his hometown the
older gretzky was fiercely dedicated to
the game
and guided a rising star from their
backyard rink
to the hockey hall of fame as michael
couture reports
the great one had to say goodbye to his
biggest fan
with jerseys on their backs and sticks
in their hands
families lined the street across from
saint mark's anglican church in branford
ontario
to pay their final respects to the man
was considered
canada's hockey dad it's just a really
sad time for the community
with everything he's done you know go to
the grocery store to see walter
going to mcdonald's he was just an
everyday regular guy
the location and the service were humble
just like the man himself
the most famous hockey dad was eulogized
by his even more famous son
we thought weeks ago that the end was
here
wayne gretzky said his father's hip
injury in february was difficult for the
entire family but
they spent the last 21 days telling
stories
he shared some of them with the few
people who were loud inside the church
due to the pandemic i don't think i've
ever met a
prouder canadian than my dad gretzky
spoke about walter's love of this
country of hockey but mostly
his love of helping children something
that was evident from how much of his
own time he spent volunteering
for a number of charities he was a
remarkable man
who loved life loved family we'd be a
way better world
if there were so many more people like
my dad outside the wayne gretzky sports
center in branford flowers and hockey
sticks were piling up by the statue
honoring walter his wife and wayne the
arena
and monument are a testament to the
family's mark on the community but it's
the memories of walter's daily
interactions with people
that many hold so dear we had
it was hometown hockey here most of the
stars were inside the arena
walter sat here outside in the cold nose
was dripping
and signed autographs like it wasn't
cold in the back of
my mind i i think about how good of a
dad he was and how good of a dad i want
to be
amazing grace
the words of so many giving comfort to
the family as they mourn the loss of
such an icon of the city the country
and the game of hockey i'm so proud of
the fact that so many people have
reached out
and given him such great tributes
because he deserves it
he has the heart of gold and
just wonderful
mike lacrouter global news
to the fight against kova 19 now the
provinces are preparing to expand their
vaccination campaigns with more doses
becoming available
in canada's largest city politicians are
calling for a 24 7 operation to get as
many people vaccinated
as soon as possible it would be a huge
shift global's catherine ward looks into
the infrastructure needed
to get this strategy going
with every administered dose of a
covid19 vaccine
canada inches closer towards life post
pandemic
i'll take it any time of the day people
would want to take it however time they
can take it because people want to get
out and do stuff with their lives
as supply increases more people become
eligible
doctors know timing is everything it's
very clear that we need to get this
done as rapidly as possible and when it
comes to timing the city of toronto will
consider a motion
at council this week for vaccine clinics
to run 24
7. councilor shelly carroll says people
want more details
this motion is about tell them what the
future looks like we're all going to get
vaccinated
however the chair of toronto's board of
health says round-the-clock clinics
have always been part of the city's
strategy toronto has
developed an immunization model that can
be scaled
at any time based on supply and so if we
have enough supply to run
24 hours and get them out faster that's
exactly what we're ready to do
experts say the location of the clinics
also plays a key role to ensure as many
people as possible
choose to get vaccinated we know we have
people who are shift workers for example
or who can't get take time off work
during
traditional business hours and so they
need to be able to have
access all through the day and night
should the 24-hour clinic model be
replicated in other parts of the
province
family physicians say they are ready and
willing to help many family doctors
have signed up for these mass vaccine
clinics that are going to open
and they're ready at the ready for the
moment when they open
if we added shifts that were going to be
overnight i know my colleagues across
the province would be prepared to step
up catherine ward global news toronto
the federal government is under mounting
pressure to address accusations of
sexual misconduct in the military
the defense minister in particular is
facing intense scrutiny
over the handling of allegations of
inappropriate behavior by former chief
of the defense staff
general jonathan vance this week on the
west block mercedes stevenson speaks
with ndp leader jug meat singh about
whether he still has confidence in the
defense minister mercedes
robin last week the former military
ombudsman said that he tried to present
the defense minister harjit sajin
with proof of sexual misconduct
allegations against former chief of the
defense staff general jonathan vance
but that sajin refused to look at the
evidence
i asked ndp leader jagmeet singh if he
thought the defense minister
should have told the prime minister
about concerns the ombudsman had raised
with him
there's no way something as astounding
and as as serious as that that testimony
was just shocking that evidence was
brought forward and presented
and and there seemed to be an
unwillingness to do anything with it
so far from what we know it looks like
there was this case of the hot potato no
one wanted to
look at the evidence when that's what
everyone should be doing
trying to get to the bottom of this
making sure that people are safe making
sure
allegations are pursued or investigated
singh would not say if he believes sajin
should step
down the chair of the house of commons
defense committee liberal mp karen
mccribben a military veteran herself
says there is nothing more that sajin
could have done
because the ombudsman brought him quote
confidential and unactionable
information i asked the committee chair
how the minister could evaluate that
evidence
when the ombudsman says he would not
look at it
here is her response he sent it to he
sent it to the pco and said to the pco
you go and do a look at this evidence
tell me if it's
what if there's something here i can do
but the
privy council office which is an
independent
non-political outside the chain of
command organization who do this all the
time it's their job
to do this for governor and council
appointments
following concerns about the military
investigating itself and calls for a
more robust
external oversight process the prime
minister said on friday that the
government is looking up setting up a
quote
more independent process to investigate
allegations of sexual misconduct in the
military
but there are no details so far on
exactly what that process
or those changes might look like robin
mercedes stephenson in ottawa thanks
mercedes global news has obtained
documents about an early warning from
the privy council office related to the
vance case
back in 2018. you can read it at
globalnews.ca
global national in india thousands of
farmers blocked a major highway to mark
the 100th day of protests against new
agricultural laws
they used tractors and their own bodies
to stop traffic just outside new delhi
for five hours
for more than three months tens of
thousands of farmers have been demanding
the controversial laws
be repealed they say the new rules will
hurt them by opening up the agriculture
sector to private players but india's
government says the laws are much needed
reforms
to modernize the country's agriculture
industry
the ongoing tensions in india have
ramifications in canada
for the large population of
indo-canadians living in this country
and for prime minister justin trudeau
who's had a rocky relationship
with india's prime minister abigail
beeman reports
for months tens of thousands of farmers
have taken to the streets in india
protests have at times been violent more
than 200 farmers have died
they began after the government
introduced three new laws aimed at
liberalizing trade
protesters largely seek are worried
about their livelihood
what will happen to government
controlled markets and minimum price
guarantees
those aren't mentioned in the new laws
to take away
parts of that safety net in the absence
of other
formal safety nets and insurance
mechanisms
i think is deeply flawed it's really
disheartening
and hard to watch being here but
the most the most inspiring act
is them staying where they are and they
have said
they're not leaving indo-canadians have
been protesting daily too
this is about both the safety of the
farmers as well as repealing the laws
they're both equally important
the prime minister has voiced his
support for the farmers we've reached
out
through multiple means directly to the
indian
authorities to highlight our concerns
the narendra modi government with which
canada has had rocky relations
isn't taken kindly to that it sent a new
note expressing concerns
asking canada to investigate we have
come across reports of threats and
intimidation
to some members of the indian community
in canada
with a large sikh population in canada
some feel canadians don't have the full
story
there are indian farmers who aren't
against the new laws
i am from chhattisgarh we don't have
even a single protest out there
and some in canada feel protests here
have moved away
from farm issues there is a religious
divide between hindus and six which is
which should not happen this thing
should stop you know
we want peace see canadians are a very
important
source of votes they are concentrated in
seat ridge areas in greater toronto and
vancouver
so it's really all about domestic
politics very little to be honest to do
with what's going on back
back in india but what all this means
for canadian farmers and
exporters isn't clear so in the short
run
we don't know and that's terrible for
canadian exporters because
uncertainty is always terrible for trade
economist raji jayaraman says if the
laws come into force it could mean good
news in the longer term
with more room for exporters to enter a
huge market
but amid unrest and uncertainty
nothing's clear
for now the laws have been suspended
under review by india's supreme court
abigail beeman global news ottawa
india claims myanmar is asking for the
return of eight police officers
who have sought refuge across the border
to avoid taking orders from the military
[Applause]
security forces again carried out
violent nighttime raids in the country
also known as burma
the military is on a mission to crack
down on protesters
who are demanding a return of the
democratically elected government of
aung san tsuchi
the un special envoy warns hopes for the
security council to take swift action
is waning fast at least 54 people were
killed during demonstrations
this week at least 20 people are dead
after a suicide car bombing in somalia
the vehicle packed with explosives
rammed into a popular restaurant in the
country's capital
the powerful blast caused several nearby
homes to collapse
dozens of people were injured no one has
claimed responsibility for the attack
but police blame the local
al-shabab extremist group pope francis
met with iraq's top shiite cleric today
during his historic visit to the country
the 40-minute meeting in grand ayatollah
ali al-sistani's home
was years in the making every detail was
negotiated by the ayatollah's office and
the vatican
the two delivered a powerful message of
peaceful coexistence
urging muslims in iraq to embrace the
christian minority
the dwindling christian community has
faced violence and persecution for
decades
the pope later visited ur the ancient
birthplace of abraham
the biblical figure revered by
christians jews
and muslims coming up police under
scrutiny after a woman
is pepper sprayed with her toddler and a
witness account of the day
tiger woods rolled his suv
a rochester new york police officer has
been placed on administrative duty
he's accused of using pepper spray on a
woman suspected of shoplifting
while she was holding her three-year-old
child this incident has troubling
parallels to two other cases involving
the police department
jennifer johnson reports and a warning
this story may be disturbing
for some viewers i did not know anything
the rochester police body cam video
horrified many local residents
police confronted a woman holding her
three-year-old daughter suspecting her
of shoplifting
the video appears to show the woman
trying to prove she didn't take anything
the woman tries to flee police wrestle
her to the ground her child is heard
screaming
at one point an officer pepper sprays
the woman they handcuff her and take the
child away
bystanders watched in disgust it don't
make a difference with a black blue
purple gray person
it's inhumane i got her the incident
comes after rochester police used pepper
spray on a nine-year-old girl in
handcuffs
during a family dispute call
the board that oversees the department
says it has to do better
the officer has now been taken off the
streets pending an investigation
what we would like to see is the
handling
of things being handled in a way that
shows
sensitivity the incidents come while the
department is still investigating
officers involved in the arrest and
death of 41-year-old daniel prude
prude was naked and unarmed when
officers pinned him to the pavement for
two minutes
he died seven days later an autopsy
showed he had been under the influence
of pcp
a grand jury declined to indict the
officers but the city's police chief is
promising reform
how can we best come to a resolution
with the least amount
of confrontation the woman in this video
was eventually charged with trespassing
for staying in a store after being told
to leave
but some members of the accountability
board say the officers should have
backed off after finding no stolen items
it was the officer's action from then on
that escalated the situation city
residents voted overwhelmingly in 2019
to create the police accountability
board
to investigate allegations of police
misconduct after years of clashing with
law enforcement
jennifer johnson global news washington
still ahead sydney's cricket ground
swells with pride
you're watching global national
it's got a blown engine oh no
a report has found the engine on a
united airlines flight failed when
pilots throttled up to minimize
turbulence
the national transportation safety board
also revealed a fan blade that broke
was inspected for wear and tear in 2016
and was less than halfway to the point
of needing another look last month's
flight 328 made an emergency landing in
denver shortly after takeoff
part of the plane ended up in a
residential neighborhood incredibly
no one was hurt according to a witness
tiger woods was found unconscious after
crashing his suv in california last
month
court documents reveal a man who lives
close by heard the crash
and walked to the scene he found the
champion golfer with his face and chin
covered in blood and unable to respond
to questions
the crash left the 45 year old with
serious injuries
he shattered his ankle and suffered
multiple open fractures to his lower
right leg
police say there's no evidence drugs or
alcohol played a part
up next from syria to canada the
entrepreneur
selling peace
pride has filled the pitch of sydney's
famous cricket ground
the 43rd annual gay and lesbian mardi
gras parade is taking place in the
stadium for the first time
the seats were capped at 75 capacity so
about 36 000 people attended
usually 10 times that amount lined the
streets for the event
but there are smaller crowds this time
around because of coveted restrictions
two weeks ago australia began its
vaccination campaign
there are currently 56 active cases in
the state of new south wales
setting up shop during a pandemic may
seem like a risky business
but a nova scotia family has been
through worse in 2015 they arrived in
canada as refugees from syria
now canadian citizens they're expanding
a family business
in nova scotia ross lord has this sweet
success story
a mask hides his smile but tara khada's
eyes
still sparkle despite a depressed
economy from the pandemic
the man who fled syria with his family
is expanding his
piece by chocolate brand with a new shop
in halifax
we wanted to translate our culture and
our heritage into something so beautiful
so when you look in the arch
the turquoise that translates into the
color in our ancient syrian houses in
damascus
the peace signs you know the poetry the
peace wall behind me
the portrait is of haddad's father
isamadin
he runs the family's chocolate factory
in the town of antagonish nova scotia
where they settled after coming to
canada in 2015.
soon after he was sworn in as a canadian
citizen last year
the pandemic hit haddad says it's been
stressful for his family
but he says they have a different
perspective than many canadians
he says a bomb destroyed their original
chocolate factory in damascus
in 2012. nothing compares to
living in your house in downtown
damascus at that time
and just waiting for an airstrike really
it's it's really straight it's been
really searched for our family
during the war but when we the pandemic
came we were like we are staying home
but we are staying safe in our homes
investing in a new shop when many
businesses are barely hanging on
is another testament to a perfect
marriage the idea of peace
and the taste of chocolate peace is the
noblest value in earth that everyone
should fight for
and chocolate is a product of happiness
chocolate makes happiness right
so far so good within two hours on
opening day
more than 100 customers had arrived he's
charming he's charismatic he
understands what he's doing he creates a
beautiful product and he brings the
community in and brings us together now
that he's added new flavors
haddad plans to install a patio in time
for summer
and he's working to expand export
networks completing the journey from
hardship to harmony ross lord global
news
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is monticello on
prince edward island
we would love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you